so how is everybody okay yeah so my name
is Marco I'm a data centers here and
tells force IQ and yet today we're going
to go ahead and talk about how to
actually get close very very very close
to putting your models on production in
a very quick quick amount of time
fraction amount that's it so yeah so I'm
basically going to guide you guys
through how so using airline sentiment
data set as a proxy for customer
satisfaction essentially how would you
set up something of the sort as an
engine that can take your email
interactions which writes if you think
about so for example right like your
sales representatives that one of the
main points of contact with the
customers let me have as emails that
they're actually right and from this we
can actually see Oh a customer stay dead
Augusta relief for some particular
reason what kind of responses are again
so like I said today's demo is really
showing you how to how to put machine
learning this machine learning model on
to production using some simple text
classification techniques so first of
all I want to talk about a patch
incubating prediction I oh so so it's
actually I started off with prediction I
oh about a year ago actually worked on
this text ossification template that
we're gonna be using today and yet so
now it's actually we've donated so far
as generously donated this to Patrick
foundation where so it's going to be
available for open source for everyone
to use and to actually contribute so the
main idea here right so one we're
actually trying to put these machine
learning models on production right so a
lot of the times a lot of people like to
get focused they're very focused on what
models were using right and you know the
extra maybe one percent increase in
accuracy that using one model over
another leaves right but that's right if
you think about it I mean you can really
find almost any model implementation
that you can possibly think of I mean a
lot of the models that you'll you don't
you'll end up using it like already
implemented for you somewhere right but
the biggest pain point really is getting
your data into a format that we can
actually use to train the machine
learning algorithm right so a lot of the
times the data that we're getting is a
mess right play it in if you know if
we're a company who's serving you know
various different customers right each
of the customer each customer state is
going to be slightly different right and
so prediction io gives you a platform to
basically help you get get these models
up and running and get the data that you
need up and running in a correct format
that'll basically make easy for you to
just feed it in to whatever machine
learning algorithm that you want to use
and also as soon as you know do your
plugin comes into the prediction I own
platform you can actually go ahead and
deploy as a service like this right and
this is an extremely it's really
powerful come back right because one
thing to yes training the model now how
are we actually going to use this to
deploy sport and the cool thing is that
these scores are actually given to in
real time as will see me cool
so
so over here we're going to I'm going to
go ahead and talk about the main
obstruction here in prediction I just
something called dazhe da SE d stands
for data data source and doing a
corporator so right so this is basically
talking about rain where are we pulling
our data from what are we doing to
actually put it into a format that we
can easily just plug and chug into
machine learning algorithm right so as I
said our data is oftentimes right so you
think about what machine learning
algorithms are actually doing right
there you're essentially taking some
hydrant some arbitrary dimensional space
and mapping it back over to soak
remember from which then we can you know
decipher some sort of decision rule
based on right so for in the case of
classification write it if think our
points are you know these little points
scattered out in an n-dimensional sticky
dimensional space or right and so we're
just producing the score to actually
draw a line and be able to basically say
if it lands on one side of wine boom
boom so the legs on one side of wine
classified to over here if it lands on
the other side of the one classify over
to the other class right but
unfortunately our data usually isn't
isn't structured in this varmint so I'm
going to go ahead and well drew so okay
so continuing on with toffee so a stands
for algorithm which is as I said right
machine learning algorithm that you can
use logistic Russian you know naive
Bayes svn neural Nets whatever you want
to use to actually you know take this
input data these input vector sum sum
vector and produce a result freight
serving now our serving opponents
basically right so when when you
actually go back and you know talk to
your customer and interface with your
customer right a lot of the times you
know there's actually
meaning to what the scores that were
producing in half right or in the case
of classification right I mean you
cannot track we think of it as a mapping
to you know to this high dimensional
space to a finite set right but this
finite set actually done right so the so
for example in when we're looking at
email data is that you want to build a
spam filter right whether it's zero or
one right there's actually a very
interpretable meaning behind that
business logic that tells you hey it's a
spam or insistent so the serpent
component actually helps you put this
put this business logic into play and it
also helps you right so if you have
multiple algorithms getting trained in
your engine which I will talk about in a
sec right how do I go ahead and compose
these scores and then finally a relevant
to the previous talk evaluation metrics
right so one of the key key key key
parts of data science is actually going
through and saying which of my models
should I actually use which is the most
effective which is actually empirically
based on the data that we're given and
usually you know using some sort of
cross-validation technique or I mean you
can use different techniques well but
particular we're using we use capable
cross-validation you're right that we
can somewhat determine basically what
the EPA that an expected prediction
error it's right based based on the
notion right that our model applied on
data that hasn't been seen before right
that should produce some a significant
indication of of the octave how it's
going to perform on on future data right
which is what we're interested and now
so now basically this actually this
pipeline describes I think how any
machine learning systems that you're
going to build can be extracted into T
steps right you start out with our data
here then right it's getting sort off
into some database right postgrad
something you can see right so then the
stable source then we need to hold this
data from this data source prepare it
into a format in which our algorithm
algorithm one algorithm to doesn't
matter right they're both going to need
to have the data prepared in some format
for which they can actually use it to
train with this pole and once it's an
out once you know we've trained our
algorithms produced our predictions
right then we need to know how we want
to combine these predictions and how do
we want to actually you know give some
implement dis business logic that is
behind its predictions right so okay
cool cool awesome dope and then of
course the evaluation here is assigned a
science have to actually decide which
model that we're going to want to
interface with our customers or the
users of your application cool so over
here we kind of show how this is a so
this shows how things are integrated
into prediction I oh right so first step
here is actually getting our data into
the event server which is essentially a
huge metadata store that it stores all
your data and tags different right
metadata about it so you can actually go
through and put the correct data into
your engine and then right our data
source produces our training data and
the data preparador goes through and
takes out training data puts it into a
format again that you can use to then
feed into your algorithms awesome so I
actually want to go through and and show
how to do this with prediction I oh so
prediction io makes it very very very
easy as you'll see to get these to get
this this model actually running into
something that's actually you know you
can query on production right and so we
start prediction i/o with very simple p
0 startled so prediction I always built
on top of spark for the data processing
HBase to action for the metadata store
essentially and spray as well for the
rest api that you know we're going to
need to use to actually query our models
that we have trained in real time cool
ah so now looks like everything started
let's make sure that my vent server is
here awesome it's alive case you guys
delight I'm reading this correctly okay
yeah cool now let's make sure it's live
I have an aquarium at home and like you
know sometimes the fish I'm kidding i
was a bad joke cool we're all ready to
go alright so now I actually want to
show you how this abstraction translates
over into prediction I all right so
prediction i/o is written in Scala and
here the main component I want to show
you is awesome
cool so now here we have a query class
right so when we actually want to you
know query are the models that we have
trained we need some sort of
representation of what this query is so
remember today I'm going to show you how
to put together this customer
satisfaction engine based on emails
right so here in this case what is our
query going to be right it's based on
some collection of emails or right so or
a collection or just a text file right
right we should be able to produce a
score of whether or not this customer is
satisfied or you know dissatisfied yeah
you know just kind of hanging in them in
between now next are predicted result so
this is what we're actually going to
output to our customers right so here
category represents what is their
sentiment based on so the proxy example
based on the actual airline sentiment
wheat and what is our confidence in this
in this prediction right so you can
think of this as the problem as the
probability that it's actually falls to
that class or our predicted probability
that a customer is dissatisfied with our
product or that the tweet was labeled as
negatives cool and then the actual
result so right so when we have our
training data we know exactly what are
you know so we know whether a customer
had left or whether they've stayed right
so we actually know the actual results
that is associated to to an email or to
the two in this case the airline tweet
and then over here we actually have our
engine and so this engine as you can see
here we have to specify what our data
source is be what our preparador is
still d.a what algorithms are we use
so in this case I set up a naive Bayes
and logistic regression algorithms and
also what are we how are we going to put
together all these results and how are
we going to display them to our user so
are there any questions thus far nope
okay all right and so here I want to
show you the data that we're going to be
using today uh can everyone still hear
me know sure thank you so here so this
data set originated from one of the you
can look it up on Cagle it's an airline
sentiment it's one of the free data sets
available there so here I've already put
it into a format that is ready to go oh
nice oh cool so yeah so here it's
actually already been put into a format
that the event servers is ready to take
right so as you can see here we have
several tags on onto there so here we
have some the event time right so part
of the stuff you know when you're
actually building these things out in
production you're going to want some
sort of notion right what data do I want
to include when I actually go through
and train the model well this metadata
tag is like actually going to let you
filter the data based on based on these
different right so based on the
different event times which is basically
two notes when this event came in to
your server cool entity type targettype
event tweet over here right so as you
can imagine your datastore is probably
going to have you know not just these
email correspondences but there's going
to be right if you can imagine you can
maybe you're collecting your phone
conversations and somehow actually
taking that frequency and mapping it
over
something that makes sense in the
computer right but we need a way to
actually be able to pinpoint the data
that we want to use to train an
algorithm so in this case we're trying
to use text data to get gauge some sort
of level of well of how how satisfied a
customer is so which brings us to the
properties over here which as you see
here we have two properties that we're
going to need to actually feed this in
to our model so first as a text which
contains the tweets and mex is a label
here which just contains basically has
is this a neutral positive or negative
is a negative positive or neutral tweet
and as they actually had someone go and
like handpick them or like go through
the tweets and they kind of gauge what
whether or not they wrote in one of
these three categories but i do want to
i'll talk about this when a little later
right but if you can imagine you may not
have these things labeled so one engine
for example could be helping you out
with actually producing some sort of
categories or finding some latent
variables the latent categorical
variable for you to actually assign your
emails and as they come cool now next
step is to actually import the data into
our event server cool
awesome so prediction I oh they base it
lets you yep sorry one more time that is
completely up to you how you actually go
through and implement your data
preparatory so you basically just need a
plug in these four steps right the where
you're pulling your data from you need
to specify you know where it's coming
from what data you're actually want to
look at and then you're preparador stage
right what it so whatever data you ended
up including and I'll show you the data
source right now and in a sec just to
kind of see how that how that works out
but yeah I mean it's completely
dependent up to you but I mean yes if
you put some logic for missing fields
right you I mean you you just need to
implement that in and then once it's
once it's in is into the preparador
right you just need to hit your p.o
build pio train vo deploy a sneak peak
did but yes you can handle whatever use
case you you particularly have cool so
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
app here ah let's call it
yeah it's fine thank you dope dope dope
also cool so now we have a new
application and as we see here it'll
show up again once we go ahead and do p
0 app list cool so here's our access key
which is a basically a unique ID tied to
our application and here's actual ID of
app and the name of the application
itself so now let's go ahead and import
data for our particular application so
here we just need to specify the app ID
which is given here is 3 and input
airline tweets JSON and so this is doing
a batch import and I used I use a Python
script to create to basically put my CSV
data into the station format the this
event format cool so now it's actually
imported so just all I guess I'll show
you the this the script right here so
it's just super quick script there's a
Python SDK PHP SDK Ruby SDK for you to
facilitate a lot of these things
depending on you know kind of what
you're more comfortable with right we're
just parsing out CSV putting it into
very simple format and next cool
and now i want to show you this data
source so one of the cool parts to about
prediction i also it started in an open
source philosophy and one of the big
components was the notion of a template
right so you should be able to just
write so a lot of these use cases like
lead scoring recommendation text
classification is super general one
right you shouldn't have to recreate a
lot of this logic for the same soap we
have community contributed templates
right that you can actually just pull
from and actually modify very very very
very quickly to actually get something
running super quickly so over here I
pulled our text classification template
and literally had to modify basically
how to basically tell it how to map the
labels out correctly and what the event
names were right so I have some email
data as well well I don't have it in
here right but i can always import the
email data into the app appid three
awesome and I'm not going to have to
worry about the email data that so that
the the spam the emails fam data getting
mixed up with with my airline sentiment
tweets right because again we're doing
this filter over here where we're just
want the tweet data cool all right so
I'm going to go ahead and now that our
data is imported now we're going to
actually go ahead and build out and
deploy this model so first step in to
actually getting your model into
production is to do p 0 build so this
basically takes cure your engine code
compile it does all that and just give
me one sec awesome so as we see our
engine is now ready for training next
step right so I've shown you the data
source so our preparador here right so
the data source itself the main
abstraction here is going to be the same
called observation which contains three
things label which we've already seen a
text and the category so the category is
going to be used later when we actually
want to tie right the the float label
that we've represented to this category
with to the business logic right so
whether or not this customer has had a
negative reaction neutral reaction or
positive reaction to their particular
airline experience and over here we have
two algorithms so we can put it through
we have one that's just doing a let me
show you the preparador first
and here are preparador it is actually
going to go through right it's going to
take the label the text and it's going
to go ahead and split the text apply
this tf-idf transformation over it and
basically do the data processing that we
need to in order to actually be able to
use this in a machine learning model so
here it's just using a simple simple
hashing trick to embed are our words
into a numb features dimensional space
and then from there right we can either
put it through this naive Bayes
algorithm right which we have a
regularization parameter here lambda and
lr algorithm which also has our our
regularization parameter here so let's
go ahead and hit p 0 train
and so by default right now I'm setting
it to go through the logistic algorithm
implementation also so as you can see a
now our model has been trained and it's
ready to be deployed
sweet
and
whoa cool and now as we see this guy's
been deployed and we can actually take a
look at information regarding our engine
cool so here we have the instanceid
variant ID and what engine would used to
train it tells us what data source what
parameters were used for the data source
preparador what preparador always use
the preparador parameters that are used
and also the algorithm that's been use
alongside with right this regularization
parameter here cool
and
oh god were of the curl command
alright
actually we just pull it over here sorry
I have the Carl command saved cool and
as you can see here we actually have a
little quick start for this for you guys
for you guys to get started nice
awesome so obviously I like speed and
fast motorcycles as a different but
right so here as you can see it's
predicted it to be in the neutral
category and it's also given us what the
probability is right relative to the
three categories mm-hmm so now let's go
ahead and do say something else just to
kind of show you Delta over booked my
flight now I have to drive to Los
Angeles also cool so clearly I wasn't
very happy about having to drive to la
that weekend yes because they did over
booked my flight and a let's actually
check different airlines so as you can
see actually like we're actually just
making Karl commands here and this
thing's just responding based on the
model that was trained in real time so
you virgin america o positive well sorry
just one try United all right neutral uh
Delta Delta has actually been like my
least favorite like granted it was that
one that one experience was very bad
surprisingly neutral uh cool and finally
Wow american airlines this one for sure
negative by the way yeah american
airlines sucks on okay cool so yeah so
as you can see right so super easy to
get you know from this one template
right get my data in about the toughest
part was actually parsing that CSV and
putting the data into the json format
and actually modifying those like four
lines and
from there I just again hit feel build
pio train p 0 deploy and holy crap now
you have in predictive engine that you
can actually query in real time right
and you can do a lot of stuff with this
too are there any questions for
continued
oh it's yeah so generally here so like
there's not so if you look at the tweets
they're not like super informative so I
think a good confidence court hears like
I mean it's the distribution is roughly
going to be uniform throughout for some
of these queries but right as you can
imagine as you act like in email data
when there's a lot more contacts and
like right so good question i would say
in this case for just for what I've
observed roughly like that I mean so
long as it gets past that like 40 line
it's like pretty good but again we don't
have a huge amount of observations and
you see like the tweets themselves
aren't 30 and right so if you look at
these tweets right there uh yeah I mean
it's yeah so roughly what I observed
basically from this data set is like a
lot the the actual the actual confidence
results tend to be like more on the
uniform distribution side but yeah
slight preference over 40 generally
gonna be pretty means like okay I'm
pretty confident on this right so
there's like three classes right so you
know mad yeah I don't know that was a
great answer yet wait what okay cool
in your model you're able to take in
multiple algorithm yes whatever other
learning algorithms yes so how does he
sort of combine yes so good question
actually in this case I believe it too
so yes a great question so let's
actually go back over here too sorry we
used one algorithm here but what if you
have to learning algorithms you wanted
to put it then in which case how would
that result be affected paraphrase what
I said cool just so everyone q alright
cool so yeah so if we look at here right
so here we produce a sequence of
predicted results and then we're
basically just saying how take the
result for the most confident one yeah
but I mean if you can imagine you can
put a different business logic depending
on how you want to approach this
particular problem right there any other
questions thus far just kidding so great
yeah love it bias is one of the biggest
challenges we have unique couple of
examples in your demo one was obviously
we have tweets or emails that might come
in we don't by definition that most
tweets deals are you need- engine you
don't generally negative the other one
you mentioned is as a human employee I
might come in and have to judge those
literally I am motivated to judge them
positively so bias is a huge problem we
face and whether it's machine learning
or its reporting we tend to want to
report where our bosses want to see mmm
how do you fight that in terms of this
how do you combat bias
huh that's an excellent question ah I
don't have a good answer to that right
now let me think about it but I would
imagine at some point right yes yes beer
over sure yeah i mean i would say right
like in the case where you know the bias
comes in at the you know when you're
actually labeling these things and
that's going to be pretty hard to kind
of love it I don't have a good answer
let me yes yes or next sure is a funny
will make a lot of money off that okay
awesome cool all right yeah no great
question uh-uh all right cool are there
any other questions audience before I
continue it's fine it's okay i was just
curious about how you might use this
with a cohort analysis of sorts just to
sort of think of a historical trend to
really understand i mean he asked about
bias but a lot of that could also be
looking at one factor and seem to be
able to predict where the next step
would be based on previous data mm-hmm I
don't I don't I don't know I know you're
not specifically talking about solving
that but I'm curious to know how you
think about that of a historical view of
predictions because a lot of this is
based on a one-time data set what
happens now when we have multiple data
sets are the same factor the same object
um so I mean there are a few ways that
you can encode time right you know one
thing is actually including it into the
features themselves right so say I mean
one example would be like say emails for
this user / this week emails for this
user for this week right emails right so
you can have kind of put together these
sort of vectors and then at that point
right I mean even just doing thinking
about as simply as a linear regression
right then you're just doing a linear
model over the right the I mean using
these time features and that's a
simplest solution I mean it depends on
how you want to model that really like
I mean that would be I mean just
plugging it in I mean more directly is
just right like you're feeding this
matrix of features right can encode that
time information right on different data
points in space mmm think that's at
least one simple way that you can that
you can incorporate that right and right
so here these event times would allow
you to do that right because we could
say hey and right so we're using the
hashing track so we can even like right
so if you think about it that way like
we're going to have these huge huge
vectors right so you can actually
control that may be a little bit more
depending on what your computing
capabilities are going to be right but
yeah and yeah I mean it depends right so
that's going to go in again to that a
the algorithm and how you want to
actually represent this data right and
even that data source preparador like I
may not necessarily be using a model
that requires me to embed my data into a
real vector space right like I could
actually be using something like I mean
like random forests right man doesn't
matter right at that point right we can
input both categorical and dimeric
features into this model but I mean yeah
so it depends on how you would want to
kind of phrase that but yeah I mean that
would go I would say roughly into the
data preparador right and a data
preparation and also how you actually
choose to model this right but if you
you know if you encode these type of
time in to enter your features in that
way right you are in a way getting a
sense of how you know how these things
change over time and including that into
your model right all right
awesome so now i'm going to go ahead and
kick the sky out sorry it seems going to
plate here
alright so now it's not another cool
thing here and so actually this is kind
of going back to your question on the
data collection right so in this case
you know there were people that were you
know going through this data reading the
tweet and then saying oh is this
positive negative neutral right but as
you can think there might be a better
way of actually of actually being able
to do this right so you can think right
potentially you could run some LD a
model run lda and how this lda basically
produce clusters or cluster assignments
right in that case that kind of takes
out that that different component or the
component of right human ear but now
when it goes when it comes through to
actually write so now that I want to
actually make a new prediction and all
I'm getting is a email then how the heck
do i connect the prediction from el día
and how the heck do I then use that
label and right feed it in to my next
query which is like okay now predict
where I want to send this this customer
right so here we actually introduced the
notion of an engine variant cool and so
one of the cool parts about prediction I
oh is that we can actually deploy
multiple engines deploy them as services
on different ports by simply modifying
so right so I've already built my engine
don't have to go through this again and
now sweet
so that's up so this engine JSON right
so once you've actually gone through and
built out and built your your template
right so there are different parameters
that you can say and which parameters
that you want to use right for for the
predictions and right you don't have to
rebuild this again it'll actually just
parse this JSON for you when it goes
through the deployment and it's all
right in the training phase it'll
actually go through parts this JSON and
map the parameters into there so as you
see here here we're only using this lr
model and here as you see we have this
red bram here red pram here likewise if
you looked at the preparador at the
preparador parameters that we were using
we add this Ngram none features and SCP
mi cool so now let's say I want to use
let's say I want to do a/b testing
actually and I want to test out two
different algorithms say naive Bayes and
here we're going to set our lambda
one point oh cool so much quicker all
right cool so now we can actually just
go through the training process again
this time specifying this new the this
new set of engine parameters it'll go
through do the training process awesome
cool engine JSON and this time I'm going
to go ahead and deploy this on porch 800
dope so now as we see here we have this
this engine deployed using the logistic
regression and this sunjin deployed over
here using the naive Bayes model and we
can actually take a look at our new
engine over here so as you see this
engine right here is now using this
naive Bayes algorithms and likewise here
we're still going through oh no oh yes
oops I'll Seuss okay thank you
awesome yeah so as you can see here this
engine right here is now using the cell
our model the logistic regression and
over here yeah we have our queries so
now as you can see here we can actually
still talk to one model awesome american
airlines and still talk to the old model
so this one here awesome cool so as you
can see now we've actually deployed two
different models two different engines
on yep so can you try I really wanted to
drive to LA today thanks Delta like well
sarcasms in general pretty hard I really
wanted to drive to LA so no it doesn't
all right yeah yes both bottles weren't
positive maybe that banks is getting
grid so yeah I think in general like
with NLP problems that's gonna be
sarcasm I mean something like sarcasm is
gonna be extremely hard to uh yeah i
mean that's that's a very tough thing to
actually get out cool awesome so right
so driving point here with this right so
now we have these different multiple
engine variants they're both deployed on
different ports so first of all what's
one use case of this right now you can
actually a/b tests on your customers
right then one side of the group over to
port 8000 and send another side of the
group 2.8 001 another thing you can
start doing yep assuming you can keep on
importing data and featuring or more
yes so is there an easy way to prune
darina so say i assume that i found out
that this week of data is probably bad
so is there an easy way to prove that
and then retrain really yeah it's
actually yeah so over here if you look
at this over here right so we have an
instance ID so if for some reason at
some point you notice that your data has
been corrupted right you can oh actually
always roll back to a previous model and
deploy that model it'll actually do the
deployment it'll unda ploy the
previously held model and deploy sorry
yeah it'll unda ploy the new model that
you that now has been corrupted with you
know bad data and go back to the old
model it'll do the deployment on
deployment seamlessly right so it'll
actually like it'll end deploy from the
port and do it for you like in the
millisecond fraction of time but yeah
it'll take care of that for and you can
always go back in time and actually
start using and then at that point right
so it's not going to solve like about I
thought what your date has been corrupt
but it'll at least give you time to look
into what went wrong and how can we
actually fix this right and also right
so this event time that we have when we
throw our data into the event server we
can always so I mean it for some reason
right we couldn't actually go back and
filter this database but we know right
but we know that week week and it out of
a weekend in the year was the one that
was corrupted we can always make sure to
filter that data out using this event
timestamp
yes so you know from a really a really
basic perspective if you had like let's
say a major traumatic issue that would
really not be the norm you could then
say well this machine or this was
trained on a very spurious set of data
you may need to go back because this
isn't this isn't really emblematic Yeah
right so I mean it for some reason your
data pipeline just props out on you or I
mean for whatever reason that the
corrupted data might have gotten in
there you can always trace back to a
point or a model a model at a point in
time in which right you you're confident
yes yes yeah and you know for some
reason you couldn't you know that data
is kind of just stuck there for now
can't you know you can always like I
said filter that data out in future
model training but yeah I mean it's it
doesn't solve right the cleaning of the
database before you write or you know
cleaning out your data store but it'll
at least give you the tool to the tools
to be able to I mean right so if you've
deployed a previous model that you
trained it'll give you some time to
investigate yeah
ah so I mean right so in this case I
mean one way well we would you seek out
a wet scores produced for these but I
mean again that kind of depends on how
you want to model compared yeah yeah
don't have a good answer but I mean red
I guess you could always in a sense
right take the scores that you produce
kind of compare different distributions
of scores and they're kind of good I
mean just purely on ice i right or I
mean do some sort of comparison between
the two distributions I guess I mean
right if you have like a set that you
know is related to Delta right so Delta
is contained in the tux get that
distribution of scores yeah yes I mean I
would say like one way to do it they
send this set up here would be right so
let's take a look at the distributions
of yeah but basically like the the pause
yet so let's take a look at the
distribution of negative neutral
negative positive and kind of how that
compares to the actual district the
distribution between the two right so I
mean at that point we're just doing some
sort of comparison of the two
distributions I think the critical part
of this is that your training data and
your algorithm and st. positive negative
neutral it's based on very specific
criteria it for example your George
hamil was do they have a positive or
negative or neutral experience with my
airline mmm not comparing it so yeah you
can't it's apples and oranges at that
point yeah so so I think what you would
have is in your example here's your
deployment engine is that would be where
you would have one set of training
criteria is positive neutral negative
with my airline one might be a crosshair
alliance and even then you have to be
very specific I think of for example
eyebrow routed from San Francisco to New
York that would be very you know that's
really more accuracy mm-hmm if you start
taking one model and this is the policy
and I start applying it well it's a
machine learning yeah across X question
I mean you're literally you're you're
making it up at that point and that's
why yeah it's kind of problem as well
you have to be very specific about its
its data that you've evaluated for a
very specific question and that's the
question you're answering you cannot
yell across questions right yeah so I
mean yeah so in this case right like
we're being given I mean we don't we
can't differentiate in the data like I
guess we can differentiate whether or
not it contains it but right like the
thing is like whether or not this tweet
had a positive neutral or negative
sentiment what about yes and then what I
love about your deployment is your AV
casting right so what you're able to do
here is say okay I think I have one set
of data so let's go back to the bias
question imagine first a scenario where
you say I feel like the cribby bias so
you didn't maybe gone to a third party
and have them reevaluate the tweets to
determine neutral positive negative and
then you did as your be mm-hmm now what
you're able to do is is do another set
of criteria of state for example of
people who I thought were negative did
they rebook with my airline in the next
six months right if you know if they
were a casual traveler they come back
maybe the next three years yeah they're
a business traveler it's literally put
the next two months and then you should
determine eight was a or b better
because you're what you're trying to do
is get your model whole even more
accurate than it was before that's
what's really cool about this yeah is it
ended gives you a basic guys let me
unless you do it right because I mean it
real time yeah that's what so what
you're showing is that's what you're
trying to accomplish at this stage of
the game right yes yeah that's awesome
uh actually can everyone yeah yeah
Marlon some bling can I also do a grid
search or something on the Marvel Bates
so actually here yes actually I haven't
gone over the eval stage but so yeah so
the way that we do the evaluation here
rights over here we give it we have to
define a metric from which we actually
were using to compare the models so in
this case just simple accuracy every can
imagine you can compute other metrics
here and then over here so we do do a
grid search on there so not as much
right so notice oh I mean depending on
how you want to encode your weights as
right because the hyper parameter here
in this case like take for the logistic
regression is going to be that right
that regularization parameter right but
yeah I mean so long as you can formulate
this yeah right so I mean I guess in
this particular case no it's not doing a
grid search over weight over your model
weights but it right so where where the
evaluation is going to come in is what
right at what level on this real number
line is this is going to produce the
optimal yeah instead of weights
Yeah right so at that point right so
I've like after you've seen kind of how
people react to this and now you have
some prior beliefs as far as to how to
combine these then yeah I mean you can
at that point right so like your scores
are producing probabilities and you can
define this to be to some sort of
mixture based on the prior beliefs that
you've observed I mean from how your
customers are reacting to the different
models and again the different
deployments can give you an idea of how
your customers are going to react ok coo
coo oh sorry awesome all right like I'll
show you the eval real quick so right so
once we've set that up there just
Oh
nope
so yeah and as you see for the e for the
for the actual evaluation we just need
to specify basically what class we're
using to compute the metric and then
what set of engine parameters and then
it actually goes through it does all
this for you yep and then as you can see
it actually prints out the best
producing result and it actually does go
through and modify the engine JSON for
you so that at that point right you can
now just go ahead and deploy and it'll
pull a the model the best model that was
found so yeah so I think the main thing
I want to I want you guys to take away
from this is really like how easy it was
for me to actually write so literally
going in from the template I had to
modify you know very few lines in actual
code to get this thing to work though
like I said the toughest part was
actually parsing the CSV and putting it
in JSON format right and now we have
something that you know compiles your
project does the training for you on a
distributed environment so actually you
know does it vary so it's using a local
spark master here however right but you
can specify what spark master you want
to use it to and you know so it's it
scales and right the big biggest thing
also is I mean just the way that you can
just automatically deploy these engines
and use them as rest services right and
you can deploy different kinds of
engines these variants that we have
right for say a B testing right
connecting two different prediction
results using some right so you can as
you can imagine right you have an HTTP
service that's saying okay I take in
this request based on the type of
request right hand it off to this model
and then this guy responds back with
saves another certain response and then
once we get that type of response right
then deliver it out to the next model
right so I mean is you can imagine right
these things are
just services that you can just query
via crow right so I'm going to go ahead
and leave it up to questions now yeah
any more questions
sounds good